Hi everyone, I'm Dogen.
Chat GPT4 has recently been released,
so today I'd like to try out whether I can use this AI tool
to study Japanese.
So I'd
like to ask you some difficult questions from the beginning.  There
is no process accent in either of the eyes
Japanese has a lot of process accents
, but there are some words with flat accents.
Candy is an example of that.
No, your Japanese is good.Are you making fun of me?Let me
ask you a simple question.Um,
what is your
favorite color?  is
not racist.  It
may give a strong impression,
but some people feel that it has health benefits.
How many
seasons are there?
There are four seasons in Japan: spring,
summer, autumn, and winter.These four seasons have different climates and
changes in nature, and
each has its own unique beauty.  It's an
important element, and
culturally it's important to feel the changing seasons.Forget the
rainy season.No,
I'm not a racist.  It
is part of the GPT 3.5 model that was
released on June 11, 2020. No, let me
retort.
What is the most delicious Japanese food?
[Music] I
'm sorry, but I eat food.
However, in general, it is said that a well-balanced meal
using fresh ingredients is
often served.In
addition, there are various types of Japanese cuisine.  There are
various delicious dishes such as city tempura, soba udon and oden, so
many people love it.
Unfortunately, the
answer was pork cutlet curry.
What do you think about the fact that most people will lose their jobs and lose their jobs because of AI, their relationships will fall apart, the gap between rich and poor will widen dramatically, and society as a whole will collapse?